seit unglaublichen 73 Jahren werden sie
in Österreich regelmäßig gewählt die
Sportlerinnen und Sportler des Jahres
neben Sportgrößen wie Hermann Maier oder
Marcel Hirscher steht ab nun auch eher
auf der Siegerliste Sportler des Jahres
mit Behinderung Johannes Aigner Ski
Alpin mit seinem Guide Harris Sportler
Matteo Fleischmann Paraolympics Gold in
der Abfahrt Silber in super Kombi und
Slalom WM Gold im parallel Slalom um nur
einige der größten Erfolge zu nennen da
fällt es leicht ein Sieger Interview von
der lockeren Seite zu nehmen
es geht nicht besser stimmt nicht als
Nicki Preisträger kommt aus Strahlen von
selbst ja das ist doch hat doch sehr
große Bedeutung das ist jetzt wieder
sowas wo man
sagenkastel stehe und
man hat es ja doch immer im Fernsehen
gesehen und dass man dann selber auf der
Bühne steht ist er doch was sehr
besonderes beim mindestens zu früh
wieder Hansi weil ich kann mich erinnern
aus ganz Kind wie vom Fernseher bin und
meine damaligen Idole oder jetzt
auf der Bühne zum stehe ist doch
unbeschreibliches Gefühl um in Zukunft
noch intensiver trainieren zu können
wird Johannes Aigner 2023 wie sein Guide
jetzt schon zum heeressportler die
Vorfreude ist groß definitiv weil dann
doch wieder mehr Möglichkeiten offen
sind zum Trainieren ich kann mit dir
dann ständig mit trainieren und
für die für die kommende Saison und auch
wieder vorbereiten und ich glaube das
wird super funktionieren so wird sich ab
2023 Verteidigungsministerin Claudia
Tanner auch über Aigners Erfolge freuen
können wenn man daran denkt dass er im
Peking 7 Sportlerinnen und Sportler
Medaillen gewonnen haben in
paralympischen Bereich noch einmal fünf
Medaillen dazugekommen sind großartige
Leistungen gebracht worden sind